UK government scientists have published
evidence which has underpinned their
response to the corona virus outbreak
the scientific advisory group for
emergencies sometimes known as sage has
been providing ministers and officials
with advice while Sky's Rowland man
Thorp joins us now from Westminster many
people been calling for the publication
of this data and the scientific
underpinning of the government's
approach here but it does look doesn't
it when you look into the detail Roland
like their 12 weeks to send this thing
packing doesn't seem to stack up with
what report contains yes it really does
and I know that when the Prime Minister
said that he was trying to inject as he
might put it some pep in the nation give
us a bit of hope but I do wonder if he
may come to regret that statement I mean
what we've just got here is a dozen or
so scientific documents they're long
they're in detail it's great to have
them and it will take a bit of time to
look through them so I hope you'll
forgive me if I just pick out one which
seems to me especially important is this
one I'm going to heart I'm gonna hold it
up so you can see a little bit of it
it's the consensus view on behavioral
and social interventions from the 16th
of March so this is really not kind of a
whole load of different different
opinions which we need to pass this is
what the government advisors generally
agreed to be true there are five points
here I think you can see on your screen
there are five points here and what
you're seeing in those points is the
government working through its different
options and it explains in very clear
terms how we got to where we are today
point one what you see there it was
agreed that a combination of case
isolation household isolation and social
social distancing of vulnerable groups
is very unlikely to prevent critical
care facilities being overwhelmed put
simply what they're saying is just
isolating specific groups probably won't
work point two says that general social
distancing is unlikely or it's unclear
whether that will be effective so
they're not really sure about that point
three and this brings us up to the
present day
they say that they agree that for
example school
closures and household isolation could
be effective when it's kept in place for
a long period and now we come to point
four and this is where what I think is
really important here they say that
these measures to be effective would
need to be in place for at least most of
a year quote under such a policy at
least half of the year will be spent
under the stricter social distancing
measures in other words there'll be a
bit of alternation half the year we'd be
a that would be able to to have kind of
less strict social distancing half the
year very strict this is possibly even
more strict than we are currently seeing
with school closures and everything
that's a year that is considerably
longer than twelve weeks that we are
going to be responding to this and again
I should stress when what the Prime
Minister was talking about he was
talking about flattening the curve or
kind of damping down the sombrero as he
likes to put it he was talking about the
Medical Response this is the behavioral
and social interventions but reading
this it brings home exactly what this is
going to mean for all of us